we haven't talked since season one
season three
now um what's it been like just living
in the star trek universe
you know like it's for three years i
guess now
i mean it's just been a dreamy thing
yeah
it's like a total bonus round situation
i i've been a nerd since i was a little
kid
yeah i never imagined myself in these
things i always just thought i'd be an
eager and happy audience member yeah i
really didn't i think
if i see it if i would go see plays or
musicals i would go yeah i could do that
i would be in that maybe but yeah
i really just never thought i thought
i'd be doing other things yeah not that
i didn't want to i
didn't think it would be possible so
it's still continues to be
really wild if that's the case yeah do
you still feel kind of
like you're is this my life and you walk
on set and you're in your costume like
does it
i feel i feel comfortable i feel
accustomed to it yeah comfortable but
it's still bananas yeah i want to take
the extra step back
yeah um this year uh in in season three
there's a wonderful new
young actor that that has joined um part
of the
story that i've that my character in
particular gets to spend a lot of time
with
cool and i've and i've kind of been like
a mentor
and part of what i've been mentoring is
like i don't know to what degree this
actor will be part of like the
the you know promotional whatever
whatever or the start being part of star
trek but
you know just saying like this is my
experience just trying to share
the wonderful doors that could open and
incredible opportunities and
and experiences and the kinds of things
people say to us and
share with us about the impact that star
trek has made it not just our show but
start just
you know the whole thing it's really
really meaningful
um so what's it been like for you then
having jonathan frakes on set and
directing episodes is that like a ho
well it's yeah i mean it's just he's
he's now become a good friend
and you know he's directed i think i
can't remember exactly how many now four
or five
all in the three seasons and uh we are
always
very happy when he's coming because he
he's
really got great energy and that's super
fun but we also know will be very well
taken care of from a
storytelling perspective and an acting
perspective and
you know it's going to look great
certainly but it's also going to feel
right yeah
um were you excited just like the rest
of fans when you found out picard was
coming yes
are you like um is there a possibility
for crossover well i thought
is there a possibility i know quickly
dash but um
no we were we were actually at star trek
star trek las vegas
uh 18
2018 when patrick
announced that it was happening so we
were in the room
oh that's when he stood up there and we
had gotten we knew about it yeah
but to be there when he announced it and
to see the response but also to see
his response to the response was really
incredible
because you probably know that he had to
be convinced yes i did understand
yeah of course because he had this
incredibly special experience right you
want to do it right
yeah so he went through this whole
process to come to say yes
and then when he shared it with the
world and the way that it came back and
you could
he was visibly shaken
moved by it in a really meaningful way
so yeah all of that that's awesome i was
like
i'm here for this yeah um what are you
excited for the fans to see when it
comes to stamets in season three
um i alluded to it i mean one of the
things is the this relationship with
this new character
um is a really special it's been very
satisfying for me as an actor and as a
person to get to
work with a with a young actor um and be
kind of uh
you know yeah mentor-ish but also like
this young actor is
phenomenal so to be inspired you know in
that way
because and that's it's also really
great the stuff with hugh is
just gonna finally like mostly like okay
i think we're on good
you know good footing yeah that was such
an emotional moment between you two and
at the end of season two loved it yes so
they're good
yes yes we're good okay yeah touch it
nevermind i never know what the writers
are gonna come up with down the road
how did you react and you found out
there was going to be this massive time
jump
i'm excited i mean it's exciting i know
that the the i think there's a good
number of fans who
that at least i've seen expressed over
the years like they're
they've been hopeful that they'd get to
see
past where the stories had gone before
and now we're even
farther past so i think it's cool
and uh you know i think we're exploring
some really interesting
uh dynamics of what that future might
look like yeah um you've talked very
openly about the importance of diversity
in this industry why are you so
passionate about that
well i mean i just know that store
people need
to have themselves reflected and the
difference that that can make
and you know for so long there was just
such a blind spot to it
yeah and it's you know i when i was 10
i did the king and i you know which is a
story that takes place in thailand
siam um and even then in 1982
there were some actors in the show who
were asian and there were some actors
who were white wearing asian makeup
and you know i was 10. i don't even know
what i don't know is if the asian actors
at the time were like
what's going on there just wasn't room
to talk about it it wasn't a thing that
people were even like
pushing the edges of and then finally in
the
you know late 80s it started and now
that we're finally at a point where
yeah the stories that can be told should
be about everyone and everything
yeah and it's yeah it's just it's just
deeply deeply important there's you know
there's all kinds of people who live on
on this planet and they all need to be
in the light
you